what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another episode of
our versus series here on patreon we're
actually gonna make this video public so
people over on the main youtube channel
are aware of what kind of stuff we do
and also because of spider-man week and
we have a really interesting match up
with two versions of spider-man going
head-to-head as we pit the original
spider-man peter parker against that new
hotness spider-man miles morales deadass
we're doing miles morales y'all you guys
like people on twitter have been asking
me to say that for a while because like
i said it in a tweet like deadass people
didn't believe that they're like i don't
know maybe they just couldn't imagine me
saying that but regardless before we
decide which is truly the superior
spiderman we're going to go over the
origins and powers of each character and
we'll start with the og peter parker and
because spider-man is one of the most
well-known characters in the world i'm
sure you've all heard his origin
multiple times so we'll try to be brief
in describing it here so peter parker
was a kid who was bitten by a
radioactive spider and got powers okay
now as for his powers peter parker
possesses superhuman strength speed
durability agility reflexes leaping
abilities and a healing factor now
spider-man is able to lift multiple tons
and is able to pick up trucks tanks and
has even held up a jet and the daily
bugle skyscraper not at the same time
but like he's held he's held them up
like at different points in time and
this is an area where spider-man is
consistently underrated which is
understandable to an extent because he
exists in a universe with characters
like hulk and thor but we really
shouldn't forget that spider-man is
freakishly strong in fact if he didn't
pull his punches he would be straight up
punching the heads off most of his
enemies now in addition to his strength
peter has insanely fast reflexes so fast
that he can dodge bullets his durability
is much higher than that of a normal
human and he can recover from damage
quickly thanks to his healing factor now
the amount of damage he can heal from is
not infinite as his healing factor is
not on par with people like wolverine or
deadpool but he can still heal very
effectively from most injuries now one
of peter's signature abilities is his
spider sense which is the tingling
feeling he feels that warns him of
impending danger which greatly reduces
his reaction time and then of course you
know he can crawl on walls and do
whatever a spider can do except make
webs now despite the fact that we most
often see spidey swinging around the
city on ropes made of spider webs making
webs is actually not part of peter
parker's power set the webs are actually
generated by mechanical web shooters
that peter invented shortly after
becoming spider-man because he's also a
scientific genius now in addition to
swinging around cities spider-man also
uses his webbing as a projectile weapon
or a nearly inescapable sticky substance
in which to restrain his enemies now
going up against peter parker we have a
guy who in all honesty i actually like
more than peter parker miles morales who
is created by brian michael bendis and
sarah pickelli or pacelli i've heard it
pronounced both ways and he first
appeared in ultimate fallout number four
in 2011. so miles originated in marvel's
ultimate universe which was created in
the year 2000 as a line of comics where
classic characters could have their
origins and stories updated without the
writers having to worry about decades of
continuity and fans complaining and so
miles origin is tied to a chemical
called oz which was created by osborne
industries in an attempt to recreate the
super soldier serum that created captain
america now when miles uncle aaron
better known as the prowler and probably
the best version of the prowl or marvel
comics because hobie brown sucks when he
breaks in to steal the formula
unbeknownst to him a spider that had
been exposed to the chemical crawls in
his back now later that spider would
crawl out and bite miles morales which
gave him superpowers now initially miles
does not want to use his powers at all
but after the ultimate universe's
version of peter parker is killed by the
green goblin as miles looks on without
intervening he takes up the mantle of
spider-man and since that time miles has
become so popular that when the ultimate
universe ended he was brought over into
the main continuity and has been the
focal point of his own animated movie
now miles powers are similar to peter's
but there are some key differences miles
has all the traditional spider-man
powers superhuman strength and agility
the ability to adhere to surfaces and
crawl up walls and as fighters to warn
him of immediate threats however his
spider sense is not as advanced as
peter's now miles is able to lift
objects weighing up to 10 tons and was
able to punch through captain america's
shield with one blow although this
particular shield was just solid steel
not the vibranium alloy that captain
america shield is traditionally made of
in the main marvel universe now as for
the unique powers that miles has he's
able to make himself invisible and has
an attack called the venom strike which
is a burst of energy channel through his
gloves that can paralyze his opponents
and looks amazing in the ps4 game and
much like his predecessor miles uses web
shooters that produce a synthetic
webbing to do all the cool spider-man
stuff like swinging from buildings so in
this battle we have two characters with
very similar powers but each character
also has distinct advantages over their
opponents this is gonna be a tough one
so we have both characters with
superhuman physical attributes and they
appear to be pretty much equal in terms
of strength agility durability and
reflexes if we were going to give an
advantage here we'd probably give the
advantage to peter just based on the
feats that we've seen him pull off but i
think they're close enough to equal that
strength will not be a significant
advantage for either one now miles also
has abilities that peter does not most
notably the paralyzing venom strike and
the spider camouflage which allows him
to become invisible and i think the
spider camouflage is going to be a
bigger factor here because obviously
becoming invisible is going to give you
a huge advantage in battle on the other
hand one advantage that peter has is
that he's a better fighter than miles
mostly due to the fact that he's been
spider-man for so long and has actually
gotten training from people like shang
chi or task master some of the best
fighters in the marvel universe so i
think miles is going to have a hard time
landing the venom strike although if he
does manage to do it then he'd be
clearly able to gain the upper hand now
as for the spider camouflage although
that clearly has potential to be a big
advantage in most battles peter's highly
sensitive spider sense is likely going
to minimize the effect because it will
alert him to which direction miles is
coming from then we have peter's
advantages one of which is that peter is
one of the smartest people in the marvel
universe which is easy to forget when
he's constantly working alongside reed
richards and tony stark but this is
something that cannot be ignored in
addition to an advantage in intelligence
peter has an overwhelming advantage and
experience since he's been spider-man
for far longer than miles has and i
think that will likely be the key factor
here as peter is just far more adept at
using his powers than miles at this
point so that experience will outweigh
miles unique powers and it will
ultimately give peter the win so that's
what we're doing here we're chalking
this win up to peter parker honestly i
think this is a good call i love miles
miles is fascinating his story is
incredible i think he's a lot more
interesting than peter parker is but at
the end of the day peter parker's just
been doing this much longer than miles
has plus the two of them also fought in
the comics of peter parker one so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end
thank you guys for watching make sure
you check out patreon and i will catch
you all later
peace